of all the people I know of all the
people I know in my life for her you
might have be the one that was most
excited about the new Star Wars movie
and so I thought there's a new you built
the religion around though and I think I
think you're one of the first people to
see it yeah what did you think of Star
Wars The Force awakens and don't hold
back all right
here's what happened with Star Wars okay
Star Wars Episode four five and six the
first ones the first ones
those were your 1970s drinking snortin
coke buddies you'd get together had fun
you got hookers together they were great
they then then they sobered up started
getting into like government and how
does Congress work a little libertarian
on the lecturing you about you know
there's actually these Maite chlorines
and I'm trying to eat healthier and then
you're like wait what what I thought
your swords cut monsters heads off yeah
and now it's like they've gone through
an ugly divorce and they're like let's
get coke and go drinking again awakens
like who a line of coke off of the
lightsaber look I do it right yeah
which really wouldn't work when you
think about it yeah or would it be
amazing yeah which camera do I turn to
hang on let me try that again
or but I need to do a turn okay Keith
ornery
or would it be amazing most guests don't
direct their own segment I really I know
how we'll just edit a camera right now
[Laughter]